according to a damning new report
England has lost a decade life
expectancy has stalled for the first
time in a century and in some deprived
parts of the country it has shockingly
gone into reverse so what is it that
happened in 2010 and had such a savage
effect on social progress health and
quality of life oh yeah
the Conservatives came to power in
coalition and introduced fair ravaging
ideologically driven austerity cuts
according to the reports author Sir
Michael Marmot this damage to the
nation's health need not have happened
that's what makes it so much worse it
was all so avoidable the Conservatives
were warned repeatedly that austerity
would plunge people into poverty damn
them to ill health and send them to
early grades but they didn't listen a UN
poverty expert said that Britain's
austerity measures had inflicted great
misery on the population but the
Conservatives accused him of bias
now this government says it wants to
help precisely those areas in the north
where health outcomes have deteriorated
but the Tories are the ones that caused
this problem why should we believe that
they're going to fix it as you say yes
we saw a decade of it austerity because
Liam Byrne left that note for his
successor David Laws in 2010 saying
there is no money left and we had a
decade of cuts that arguably contributed
to the vote for brexit and now of course
those votes have been lent to the Tories
for the duration and of course they have
to make good those austerity cuts in
order to keep those votes so you're
seeing a huge amounts of infrastructure
spending 30 you know 40 new hospitals 33
billion pounds being spent on the NHS
you're seeing a number of bus services
and the restoration of some of the
Beeching cuts in rail links and I argue
probably you'll see them particularly in
the north so the Tories are going to
love bomb the red wall because they need
to keep those votes when it comes to the
next election yeah I just want to make
one point about austerity
I mean I think we do need to make clear
that it was a choice there was an
economic crash 2008 but austerity was an
ideological response to that it didn't
we didn't have to make the poorest and
more vulnerable in our society pay for
the failures of banking you know there
was all sorts of other things we did not
have to reduce corporation tax from 26%
to 19% we could have decided that the
highest earners the 5% of highest
earners will pay a little bit more tax
but instead the government decided to
pursue a policy and austerity program
that actually made poor the poorest
people pay
I do think they've quite acknowledged
that can we just hear from Serge sorry
former just after a decade of recovery
from Labour's great recession we are
turning the page on austerity and
beginning a new decade of renewal labour
left behind a bankrupt Britain and we
fixed it
now thanks to those difficult decisions
and the hard work of the British people
we can now afford to turn the page on
austerity and move forward from a decade
of recovery to a decade of renewal I
think they will have abandoned that
their pledges towards the deficit in
order to make good but you know they are
going to boil it borrowed they're going
to spend trillions because we've still
got very low interest rate so we've got
very home poor on Sajid Javid I didn't
think I was going to see them again this
edge auntie Tory Tosh as regards the
fact sadly the death rate it is not
alone there are other countries in the
west where this unfortunate this is
appalling the moral of the age of
mobility has started to come down but
that was then this is now this is the
new Boris Johnson led government that
has breached the red wall I tell you
this you wait for the budget you wait
for the budget exactly what rachel says
but money will float quite rightly the
money will flow up north I think you
will find that this conservative
government they know that the good folk
of Seven Oaks and Red Hill will always
vote as blue as your jacket so they
don't need to worry they've not just
borrowed it they want to retain the
late-day they want if you would they
want blue labour effectively they want
to go through there and they want to own
it the money will go up there you can
condemn the previous administration as
much as you like this is not the new
Johnson government could we back up here
a bit bothered about the way that we're
wrestling what is essentially science
into a political framework the truth of
the matter is that what mom upstairs I
took the trouble to read his hundred and
fifty pages about what marmots actually
says he's very careful not to say this
is about austerity he says it's a
plausible explanation but he doesn't say
it was caused by austerity and why
because actually if you do epidemiology
sorry and gonna be boring geeky here you
will know that the most likely causes
for a fall in life expectancy or or is
he actually described don't fall it's
the
the growth in like expectance is slowed
up the most likely causes are one
smoking a piece to diet and actually the
World Health Organization tells us that
smoking takes ten years of your life
expectancy in this country among
professional media classes us 10% smoke
amongst poor working routine and manual
professions 25% smoke and my challenge
to you Rachel is honestly do we need to
get into the big political thing or
should we just actually save some lives
by getting fewer people to smoke poverty
and health outcomes are completely tied
together who wrote the report that you
read should we have a look at what he
said England is faltering from the
beginning of the 20th century England
experienced continuous improvements in
life expectancy but from 2011 these
improvements slowed dramatically almost
grinding to a halt England has lost a
decade if health has stopped improving
that means society has stopped improving
and if health inequalities continue and
in fact increase that means inequalities
in society have been increasing I just
want to clarify because you're you're
right but he was very careful we can't
say conclusively we do not have another
United Kingdom that did not have
austerity for ten years to measure one
against the other we can't say it
conclusively however what we can say is
that all the recommendations that he
made the last time he carried out this
research in 2010 so to avoid these
declines in life expectancy happening
investing in children in their young
years creating stable and secure and
well paid employment creating good
health environments and creating good
housing environments and solid
communities all of these things but
government the Conservatives who
welcomed the report in 2010 did the
exact opposite shots or SureStart
sensors shot community centres shot
youth centres cut school budgets cut
social care cut bus services cut health
service it
exactly the things that he predicted
would make the situation worse was what
the Conservatives did so that's why
we're seeing the outcomes that we're
seeing today report and he surveyed
experts and they said there might seem
the most important thing that affected
life expectancy which by the way didn't
start - didn't fall until 2015-16 was
the sugar levy it wasn't actually to do
with public expenditure more libraries
are is not going to increase life
expectancy let's deal with the things
that actually work the situation with
the north particularly for example the
Northeast has been created because for
many many years people have not given a
damn about the north it has been the run
of the litter and that has just been a
fact so I think just to say that this is
all just because of austerity I do think
that's slightly lazy and I tend to agree
with Trevor in the sense of actually
there's multiple and contributing
factors to this and I remember in
November there was a report came out
called the state of the north and it
said that home where I might have
mentioned that higher mortality rate
then Romania in whole and that really
stopped me in my tracks and it really
shocked me so this for me you asked the
question at the end of your intro about
how can we believe that they're going to
fix this NIC is absolutely bang-on
they're gonna fix this because they have
to because they're going to want to stay
in power and I actually think that lots
of these places in the north and the
Midlands that went Tory for the first
time in decades I think that there is a
very strong probability that they will
stay a Tory if this government does what
it says it will do which is invest in
those areas and we shall wait and see
we shall and that's something to which I
think we shall return